-As he continues to deal
with the aftermath
of his disastrous response
to the humanitarian crisis
in Puerto Rico,
President Trump is now also
dealing with
an internal crisis --
a simmering feud
with the Secretary of State.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
After his tour of Puerto Rico,
where he chided Puerto Ricans
for throwing the budget
out of whack
and tossed paper towels
into the crowd
like he was
at the free-throw line,
Trump did what he always does --
bragged about his performance
and made up a bizarre
and completely unnecessary lie
about how unprecedented
his trip was.
He told reporters
on Air Force One...
[ Laughter ]
You think this is the first time
a sitting President
has visited hurricane victims?
This isn't even the first time
you've done it!
[ Laughter ]
You were just in Texas
and Florida a few weeks ago.
Remember? Oh, no!
You don't remember, do you?
[ Laughter ]
This is turning
into "50 First Dates,"
but for hurricanes.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
In a way, though...
In a way, though,
Trump is right.
This is the first time
a sitting President
has embarrassed himself
this much
while trying to comfort the
victims of a natural disaster.
For example, after he threw
supplies at hurricane victims,
the crowd literally
had to tell him to stop.
According to
the "Washington Post"...
[ Laughter ]
My God.
Our President had to be told not
to throw cans of chicken...
[ Laughter ]
...at hurricane victims.
I wouldn't be surprised if he
only built Trump Tower
so he could drop pennies
off the roof.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Of all...
Of all Trump's missteps in
Puerto Rico, there's one that is
perhaps the most embarrassing
and also the most revealing.
At the church where supplies
were being handed out,
he encountered a church member
giving out
water purification tablets.
Basically, these tablets
turn dirty water
into clean drinking water,
and not only could Trump
not believe it worked,
he couldn't believe
they were giving it away
for free.
Here's how that exchange went,
according to the "Post"...
Trump genuinely cannot
contemplate doing something
out of the goodness
of your heart.
He just assumes it must be
a scam.
[ Imitating Trump ] So you give
them the dirty water,
but you say it's clean?
[ Normal voice ]
No, it's clean.
[ Imitating Trump ]
Oh, so you clean the water,
but then you sell it
for double the price?
[ Normal voice ]
No, we give it away for free.
[ Imitating Trump ]
Oh, I get it. So while they're
drinking the water,
you go around
and steal all their wallets?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] But this --
this is yet another reminder
to the evangelicals
who support Trump.
He doesn't understand church.
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitating Trump ]
What's Jesus' cut, 20%?
That's very good.
That's a lot of cans of chicken.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] But after
embarrassing himself,
insulting the people
of Puerto Rico,
and repeatedly bringing up
the financial cost
of the recovery,
Trump out of nowhere
seemed to throw Puerto Rico
a potential lifeline.
Right now the government
of Puerto Rico is dealing
with an economic crisis
and billions of dollars in debt
bought up by hedge funds
and other Wall Street firms
who have blocked any attempt to
allow Puerto Rico
to restructure its debt
or declare bankruptcy.
But as Trump was leaving
the island on Tuesday,
he seemed to suggest
he might support
forgiving Puerto Rico's debt
completely.
-We're going to work
something out.
We have to look at
their whole debt structure.
You know, they owe
a lot of money
to your friends on Wall Street,
and we're going to have to
wipe that out.
That's gonna have to be, uh,
you know, you can say goodbye
to that.
I don't know if it's
Goldman Sachs,
but whoever it is,
you can wave goodbye to that.
-Well, that would be easy.
I've been waving goodbye
to things since
you became President.
Bye, Constitution!
Bye, good night's sleep!
Bye, half the people I know
on Facebook!
[ Cheers and applause ]
But forgiving
Puerto Rico's debt
would be a truly
transformative step.
It would go a long way to
alleviating the suffering
of Puerto Ricans and make up for
many of Trump's missteps
in handling the crisis,
so naturally,
his budget director,
Mick Mulvaney,
went on TV the next morning
to tell people,
"Don't listen to the President."
-The President seemed to
suggest that he is open
to wiping out
the Puerto Rican debt.
Is that to be taken seriously
on its face?
-I wouldn't take it word
for word with that --
-Agreed. No one should ever take
Trump word for word.
It's far more fun to take
his words
and then put them in an order
that you find interesting.
-I have Wall Street friends.
I have a lot of money.
I have butt hole. I have
butt hole. I have butt hole.
Goodbye.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Very proud of that.
Of course, the President isn't
content to botch
just one crisis, which is why
he's in the process
of botching another --
North Korea's nuclear program.
The international community has
been desperately pursuing
every diplomatic angle to avoid
what would certainly be
a catastrophic war,
and Trump's own government
has been working with
the U.N. Security Council,
China, and even through
back channels
of North Korea itself to resolve
the conflict peacefully.
So once again, Trump threw
all that out the window
when he tweeted out of nowhere
over the weekend...
So all the careful diplomacy
and bargaining and angling
just goes out the window
with one tweet.
It's like everyone is playing
an intense game of Jenga,
and Trump is the rambunctious
golden retriever
barging through the doggy door.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I wouldn't be too
concerned
that Rex Tillerson is expending
a lot of energy.
He looks like the guy
sitting in a rocking chair
outside the corner store
who says...
[ Elderly Southern voice ]
Storm's a-comin'. I can feel it
in my knees.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice ] So Trump
has once again undercut
the diplomatic efforts
of the Secretary of State,
which has happened
so many times,
that Tillerson apparently
threatened to resign
over the summer,
according to a report yesterday
from NBC News.
But the fact that Tillerson
threatened to resign
is not the most damning part
of the story.
That, of course, had to do
with what Tillerson called Trump
behind his back.
-At a meeting at the Pentagon
with the President's
National Security team,
there were cabinet officials,
White House officials.
The President attended.
He left.
The group was gathering. There
were a number of people around,
and the Secretary called
the President a moron.
Wow. And Tillerson has that
great Texas accent,
so you know
he really stretched it out.
[ Southern accent ]
That guy is a more-ron.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Now, obviously,
this story was based
on anonymous sources, and
the State Department denied it,
which is why MSNBC
did their own reporting
on exactly what Tillerson said
and issued an important
clarification later that day.
-My source didn't just say
that he called him a moron.
He said "an effing moron."
[ Laughter ]
-This story keeps
getting better and better.
Seriously, I can't wait
for the next update.
Oh, here it is right here.
"Sources have further clarified
"that Tillerson called Trump
a 'straight up nose-pickin'
"'mouth-breathin',
missed-a-belt-loop...
[bleep] more-on.'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tillerson, of course, was forced
to issue a statement
at a hastily arranged
press conference yesterday,
where he took the extraordinary
step of trying to assure
the American people
that the President is not,
in fact, a moron.
-Let me tell you what I've
learned about this President,
whom I did not know before
taking this office.
He loves his country.
He puts Americans
and America first.
He's smart...
-Man, to think a guy's a moron
and then be forced
to publicly say he's smart.
I guess when your name is Rex,
you're gonna be good
at rolling over.
[ Laughter ]
Good boy, Rex! Good boy!
[ Applause ]
Oh, stay away from the Jenga!
Now, yesterday, while he was
in Las Vegas, Trump was asked
about the Tillerson story
in his comments afterwards
and could not stop himself
from attacking the media.
Watch as he keeps saying
"thank you"
as if to stop talking
and then continues to ramble.
-Yeah, I'm very honored by
his comments. It was fake news.
It was a totally phony story.
Thank you very much.
It was made up.
It was made up by NBC.
They just made it up.
Thank you all.
-Do you have confidence in him?
-Thank you.
-Total confidence in Rex.
I have total confidence.
Thank you very much, everybody.
[ Camera shutters clicking ]
-You can almost see the angel
and devil on his shoulders
wrestling for control.
[ Devilish voice ]
Say it was fake news!
[ High-pitched voice ]
No, say thank you and leave.
[ Devilish voice ]
Call it a phony story!
[ High-pitched voice ] Walk away
and don't throw chicken cans!
[ Devilish voice ]
Throw the chicken! Throw it!
[ High-pitched voice ] No,
throw the paper towels
but not the chicken!
[ Devilish voice ]
Throw the chicken,
but wrap it in paper towels
so they think it's soft!
[ Cheers and applause,
whistles ]
[ Laughter ]
We're in a truly extraordinary
situation where the President
is fighting with
his own Secretary of State,
as he faces multiple
foreign policy challenges.
In fact, cabinet officials are
apparently now so concerned
about the President's volatility
that several of them have forged
an agreement to quit if Trump
tries to fire one of them...
Jesus, so three cabinet
officials have to ban together
to deal with
their out-of-control boss.
They're treating him like he's
Dabney Coleman in "9 to 5."
[ Laughter ]
And before you say that was
a dated reference,
they were all at the Emmys!
[ Laughter ]
So this is the situation
we're in.
Cabinet officials are forming
suicide pacts
to protect each other
from the President.
The President is volatile,
unstable, incompetent.
In other words...
-A moron.
-No, that's not it.
-An effing moron.
-Yeah, that's it.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]